good afternoon my name is Jeremiah
thanks so much for coming to my talk I
hope everyone here knows this is a talk
about the perils of workflow management
and not one of the machine learning
talks is taking place right now so if
you want to take a moment reevaluate the
room you're in that's totally fine for
the rest of you I'm really happy to be
here as one of the representatives of
our DC Data community I have spent most
of my career in various forms of data
science usually in finance usually in
risk management a few years ago I became
a PMC of Apache airflow and this year I
formed a software company called prefect
here in DC I also want to mention I've
had a long very friendly relationship
with a company called quanto peein some
of you may have attended James's talk
this morning on using air flow in
productions James is an SRE Encanto peon
he's a really fantastic resource if you
want to talk about deploying air flow in
fact the first person who ever saw our
prefect work was the head of data
science at quant opions I think
incredibly highly of their company
however I do want to give some fair
warning that this is going to be a very
different type of talk than James and
the and the inspiration for today's talk
actually came from an error message task
failed successfully the more I thought
about this first I thought it was funny
and then and then I I really liked it
because this is sort of what I do I'm a
risk manager and more recently I built
workflow software so my job is to make
sure that when failure happens it is
handled correctly but even so what does
it actually mean to fail
successfully and and and maybe more
importantly for all of you how do you
turn that into actionable advice so I
think we should start with the basics
what is workflow management it's a good
question and here's what I think in a
very simple sense workflow management is
when you have things you want done and
you put a system in place to make sure
they happen and that's it our team uses
the terms positive and negative
engineering to differentiate between
these two types of work positive
engineering is the work you actually
want to do negative engineering is
everything you have to do to make sure
it gets done that's the error trapping
and handling the type coercion the data
serialization
infrastructure all of that stuff the
most data scientist data engineers want
to be writing positive code and I
believe it's the role of a good workflow
system to support them by taking on the
negative side in that sense negative
engineering is a form of risk management
now negative engineering requires you to
anticipate and defend against all the
possible ways your system could fail or
in a more general sense behave some
pessimists might say that's impossible
and others missed the point by assuming
it's easy they say well if you don't
want errors just write better code and
in my past life that would have been
like saying oh you don't want to lose
money just buy better stocks it's easy
to say very very hard to do and it's
frankly silly either way as a risk
manager I can tell you that this is very
doable in the right framework so to
illustrate what negative engineering
actually entails let's walk through an
example
so here's finally some Python this is a
simple made-up task that I want to do
and since it's what I want to do it's a
form of positive engineering but now we
are putting on our risk management hats
and we start thinking about negative
outcomes how do we defend against
failure so the first thing that most
people do is they trap the error right
it's very easy it's very straightforward
do this if it doesn't work raise a
helpful error now a cynic might note
that this just replaces one error with
another and while that's true it could
also be a case of better the error I
know
than the error I don't in either case we
can do better and so most people will
move on to retrial and so here we've
added some logic to retry the task up to
five times and it's gonna wait ten
minutes between each attempt in case the
system needs to cool down so we feel
good about this we put it into
production and immediately it starts
failing something's wrong with the
function arguments we don't have a way
to replicate it locally so let's debug
it in production and the way we're going
to do this is with very specific errors
when our arguments have the wrong type
so have we actually solved a problem
no but do we feel better about it maybe
what we have done is taken a situation
we already knew was bad
and added an explicit hook to find out
when it happens it may seem silly but
that is a totally valid negative
engineering exercise no one has ever
complained about having too much
information but now it turns out that
our task is hogging resources and when
it sleeps for 10 minutes it is still
running so our full failure cycle takes
almost an hour our team wants us to do
better so we're gonna retry
asynchronously and now in addition to
writing error trapping code we're gonna
write error trapping infrastructure
which I'm obviously not gonna bother to
write here but our function now returns
these AP likes API like status messages
so that some other system presumably can
manage it and and retry it appropriately
and it turns out we're not even done
with that sometimes you might remember
that this function which I don't even
know where it is here anymore was doing
1 divided by a result and oh sorry
and every now and then it turns out that
that result can be 0
so we need to introduce a special
handler for that zero case lest that
error take down our whole system so
let's take a step back and see where we
started and where we ended up this is
what we wanted to do this is what we had
to write to actually do it this is the
positive engineering that's the negative
engineering so yes my example is
extremely contrived but if you think
it's unrealistic then you need to talk
to more data engineers for this example
we worked with a single task to control
issues that might arise in only its
execution and that's great but even that
doesn't justify a full workflow
management system workflow managers
become much more important when we start
to deal with the dependencies between
tasks and I would argue that what takes
a series of function calls and graduates
it to a workflow with a capital W is the
fact that some process is monitoring and
managing the full state of the system
because while any task can in theory
look out for its own state and its own
failures we need something to ensure the
integrity of the system as a whole and
in order to do that we have to know how
to work with failure the simple question
is if a task has an error and no one is
around to depend on that task and does
anyone really care did it actually fail
but if someone does depend on that task
whether it's a person or another task
then all of a sudden handling that
failure becomes critical and so this
idea of failing successfully is not just
about reporting that an error happened
it's about defining the behavior of the
system once that error takes place and
this is super important because task
failure should not automatically mean
system failure
failing successfully means that failure
is a part of our system it is a state
just like success that we can work with
that we can react to and that can drive
business logic if you the designer want
to apply meaning to that failure then
that's totally fine maybe you want the
workflow to stop as soon as it has a
problem maybe you wanted to stop only
after 10% of tasks fail
maybe you expect failure and want to
react to it every single time
all of those are totally valid it's not
for the workflow system to decide
whether failure is necessarily good or
bad it's job is to reveal it promote it
and make it available for any business
purpose and that is how you fail
successfully now what happens when we
don't embrace failure when we treat it
as an outlier workflow systems are often
victims of something that in my finance
days we called wrong-way risk wrong-way
risk is the idea that your exposure to a
bad outcome is exaggerated when the bad
outcome occurs in the classic example is
that you buy insurance against some
natural disaster and one day the
disaster actually happens and you go to
file a claim and you find out that your
insurance company only sold policies to
people in your neighborhood so
everybody's making a claim and the
insurance company is bankrupt and you
wind up with nothing so you had
wrong-way risk you thought you were
insured but your insurance turned out to
be negatively correlated with the thing
that you are insuring against workflow
management systems introduced wrong-way
risk when they treat failure as an
outlier or an afterthought by not taking
it seriously or not providing
first-class tools for working with it
they [ __ ] themselves at exactly the
moment that they should be most useful
and the proof of that is simple if you
could guarantee that your workflow would
run perfectly you don't need a workflow
manager at all
just put in a script and run it whenever
you need it it's only as we start to
introduce some probability of failure
the workflow system becomes really
important it's how we're gonna deal with
those failed states so therefore if the
workflow system treats failure is
unexpected it is least equipped to deal
with the situation that we need it the
most and that is wrong-way risk now a
lot of people assume they can control
this by building robust data pipelines
but usually they were exclusively about
the data and you talk about data lineage
and data latency and data storage but
you never hear about the workflow system
itself collapsing and that's because of
a rather massive assumption that we all
make that our workflow systems are
perfect that they handled themselves the
right way and that they do not fail and
I wish I could live in that world but I
have touched almost every line of
airflows code and I can assure you that
there's nothing magic about a workflow
system it has a strength it has a
weakness and it doesn't care how much
time you spent on your ETL checks it
will fail if you don't use it the right
way
so you haven't set yourself up to fail
successfully you haven't set yourself up
to succeed in any way at all if you
don't play to your workflow system
strengths we can see how this will play
out this is what a workflow system is
supposed to do it's supposed to protect
against problems that's the negative
engineering aspect it's supposed to
promise that work will get done that's
the positive engineering side and of
course it needs to provide us with the
tools that we need for working with the
results of those tasks good or bad but
what really happens is quite different
first workflow systems compromise in
order to make good on their promise to
protect against failure they limit what
they let you do because you can't do
very much they don't have to defend
against very much and they minimize the
number of things that can go wrong so
the first sin is the compromise the
second sin is the cheat the cheat is how
we get around the compromise if your
workflow system is compromised because
it doesn't handle retries it's no
problem just write a script like I did
before that does the retry yourself at
the end of the day it's all code and you
can do whatever you want the only
question is whether your code complies
with the expectations of your workflow
system so that might not seem like a
problem but it can be really really
dangerous you end up
effectively running two systems neither
aware of the other and without any
common vocabulary for understanding what
the other ones doing and that leads to
the third sin corruption all workflow
systems are designed with a philosophy
of how workflow should behave if it's
not written down then it's expressed in
what kind of tasks they can run and what
the contract is that those tasks fulfill
the reason the previous sin was called
cheating is because we were forcing the
workflow manager to do something
contrary to its philosophy contrary to
what it was designed to do and that
corrupts it how do you record a tasks
retry attempt if you don't know what a
retry is how do you decide if a task is
ready to run based on data if you don't
track data dependencies how do you
resume from a failed state if your
system was designed to exit on failure
this is the most common type of airflow
bug we see it happens when you try to do
something that airflow doesn't really
understand but lets you do anyway the
system gets corrupted recovery can be
impossible how would you like to see
some examples first up something called
X coms one of air flows compromises is
that tasks communicate purely by a state
in this case success or failure and
therefore there is no way for them to
exchange data or information people kept
coming up with ways to get around this
so a few years ago we cooked up
something called X coms which stands for
cross communication to a user X comes
look like a first class way to move data
between tasks but from airflows point of
view air flows are excuse me ex-cons are
a hack they're definitely a cheat under
the hood and don't worry too much about
this and the XCOM is just a way for
tasks to impersonate an admin user and
write arbitrary data to the airflow
database tasks push or pull information
from the database which creates strong
data dependencies between tasks and
these data dependencies can exist
between two tasks between two dads or
even between a single task and a past or
future version of itself it is a very
rigid and error-prone form of dependency
and the kicker is that airflow the
system we use to manage dependencies has
no idea it exists it has no vocabulary
to describe or enforce a database
dependency
and so the single most common airflow
bug we see is users who have used X
comms to hack strong data dependencies
into a workflow system that doesn't
track data dependencies what this means
is that if a task ever fails and
therefore doesn't push the XCOM the next
task is also gonna fail an airflow has
no idea why because we just we went
outside the system it leads to a very
frustrating chain of failures even worse
X comms are serialized into the airflow
database with no way to delete them and
no exploration so if you're processing a
10 gigabyte data frame and you pass it
through 100 tasks then every single run
is generating a terabyte of permanent
storage which is just it's sort of
insane and it all begs the question
should I use X coms and the answer is
probably not and the punchline
is that that's me okay I wrote X coms
about 3 years ago because I was
frustrated by this problem and I own
this cheat and I regret it and the truth
is I don't think airflow is usable for
data science without X comments I think
you need to move data around data
dependencies are just too important in
the modern data stack but when I
designed these X comes I was using them
to pass around tiny little bits of
transient information and I remember
Maxime he's the original developer of
airflow telling me that the system was
prone to abuse but I didn't listen I
just I thought this was too important to
include in the system but sadly as I
said it's become one of the largest
source of largest sources of untraceable
bugs in the air flow world so watch out
for your ex comms
the next thing I'd like to talk about is
something called the branch operator
just by truth the branch operator allows
us to include branching logic which is
pretty fantastic we need that a lot of
the time and it's also pretty amazing
because it's not possible in air flow
the same compromised functionality that
led me to make X comms says that there's
no way for a single task to tell
multiple downstream tasks that one of
them should run and the other shouldn't
all it can do is return success or
failure but branching is important so so
what do we do and of course we cheat we
don't need to look too closely at the
code but but if you do look in the code
you'll see that the task is calling a
method called skip
and that seems kind of reasonable that
it would call this method that lives on
itself until you ask well why is this
task skipping itself and the answer is
it's not it's actually skipping the
tasks that goes after it
so the Skip method is another backdoor
into the air flow metadata this task is
manipulating the state of a task that
hasn't been evaluated yet and from a
data integrity standpoint that should
horrify you right airflow the system
that tracks dependencies and enforces
contracts between tasks is letting a
task impersonate an admin and mess
around with other tasks it's a
completely untraceable form of
dependency and it's the most pure
violation of air flows philosophy that
I'm aware of but it's incredibly useful
so we forgive it and in the interest of
time I'm going to move through some of
the some of the texts but these will be
available later for you to read the last
example that I want to run through in
detail is about the intersection of air
flow state and business logic so this
isn't so much a compromise actually as
it is a choice remember that a good work
flow system is supposed to track state
but be agnostic to how it's used for a
business purpose to agnostic to what it
signifies and that's what lets us fail
successfully we elevate state to a place
where you can make decisions based on it
so this is an interesting situation this
is a work flow that has two tasks one of
them is very important it does something
that you care about and the other one
just cleans up if the first one has a
problem so on the left this is a
situation where the important task was
successful and we didn't even bother
running the cleanup and I think we all
agree with air flow that that is a
successful run of this workflow but on
the right we have a situation where the
important tasks failed and the cleanup
task was successful now air flow thinks
that this run was successful and to be
honest I don't know if it was or wasn't
that's up to the person who designed it
maybe they only care that the workflow
ran and so yes they would like to see
this as a green light on their dashboard
but I can easily imagine the situation
where someone cares deeply about the
important first task running in which
case they'd like to see this as a
failure but air flow does not give you a
choice
air flow has it hard-coded the task
State excuse me dag State is always
determined by the last tasks in the
Dagon so this is a design failure this
means that our workflow system is not
capable of reflecting business logic and
therefore we cannot fail successfully
the system is corrupt again skip some
texts in the interest of time and we'll
just move very quickly if you're
interested through a couple of other
quick examples people use airflows
global variables in place of parameters
which Justin creates a very staple mess
people abuse the fact that airflow
reruns a dag every single time it runs a
task to introduce tags that change while
they're running which I don't even have
to tell you how horrifying that should
be off-schedule runs air flow used to
not support off schedule runs we
eventually sort of found a way to make
it do it and we found that this this
assumption was so baked into the system
that both the scheduler and the UI broke
as soon as we ran something off schedule
in particular the schedule was working
by adding an interval to the most recent
run so if you had something ticking
along every hour it was totally fine
then all of a sudden if you ran
something on the half-hour the scheduler
would start adding the hour to the
half-hour time and and keep going from
there so again the idea is that these
these are not impossible you can make
the system do whatever you want but if
you don't respect the assumptions of the
system you're going to end up in an
unexpected place and the last one I'll
talk about is that air flows database
has a unique constraint on a dag in its
execution time which means that you
cannot run a dag twice at the same time
it doesn't support the concept of
simultaneous runs of the same dag now if
you live in air flows world that's
totally fine that makes sense if you
live in my world where I want to run
workflows all the time no matter what
for any circumstance that makes no sense
at all so that's a that's a big problem
to me I think it's extremely important
for me to note that these problems did
not start with air flow and they are not
unique to air flow I just happen to know
them very well in an air flow context
from solving users problems I want to
repeat that all work flow managers have
strengths and weaknesses and identifying
these weaknesses doesn't automatically
mean it's bad it's just a benchmark for
you to measure your appropriate use of
the tool against and we can see how this
has played out through history
all right so in the beginning there was
cron and in fact cron I was very
surprised to learn they saw the way back
to 90
87 and I'll bet that every single person
in this room has written a cron cheat
because cron makes the compromise of
course that there are no dependencies so
if you want two things to run in
sequence you schedule one for midnight
you schedule one for 1:00 a.m. and you
hope they work that's the crunchy and
after cron we can move pretty pretty
quickly this is Uzi which is cron in
Java and XML
this is Azkaban which is cron with
dependencies this is Luigi with
dependent which is cron with
dependencies that are based on side
effects SPARC is an interesting one to
mention it doesn't feel like it fits in
this pattern of data engineering
workflow managers but if you have spent
enough time in both the data engineering
world and the data science world you'll
quickly remember that spark and other
tools like it including beam task even
tensor flow these are just ways of
describing computational graphs and
moving data or some state through them
so it just happens that SPARC passes
data instead of States but it's the same
idea and last but not least of course we
have air flow which I would basically
describe this cron with a database so
the question is what have we learned
from this history of work flow
innovation which by the way I think
stopped in 2015 this is a quote from the
creator of Luigi said all workflow
engines kind of suck
including Luigi the question is well why
why do they have to second and one
answer is that they were originally
created to solve a specific problem at a
specific company which means that while
we can today point back and say yeah
they were compromised
they weren't compromised in the moment
they were appropriate to the task at
hand it's only once they were open
sourced and attempted to be widely
applied that these compromises became
evident and in the ahta in the absence
of a modern alternative they've become
weighed down by all of these cheats that
I've been enumerated a common response
from the authors of these platforms
including myself is that users should
just write idempotent tasks does
everyone know what idempotency is it's
it's it's basically the idea that if you
run something multiple times it'll only
cause an action once so this is sort of
like the get-out-of-jail-free card of
data engineering and data engineering
you know workflow authors because of
course if you have an idempotent task
it'll work that you could use cron and
just spam a server every two seconds
with a bunch of item potent fast you
don't need a workflow manager
so it's like yeah this is true but does
it really matter is it practical and the
answers is no it's not so I'd like us
you know you know to look to be clear
idempotency is good but we need to live
in the real world where it's unlikely
and possibly impossible and perhaps
impossible and so instead of pretending
that people can write perfect code let's
acknowledge that they write bad code and
see what we can do to support them in
today's talk I've shown that these
workflow managers they commit these same
basic sins over and over and because
they implement compromise limited
functionality they end up cheating to
implement the features they want how can
we overcome this we need to start with
what users actually want to do and if
you're the users in this room what you
want to do is you want to write Python
so this is what you know the the
simplest ETL script I can imagine looks
like in Python and this is an example of
positive engineering this is what you
want to do how would we design an
idealized workflow system around this
code well if you think about it almost
everything we need is already here right
we know what the what the tasks are we
know what the workflow definition is we
just need a way to communicate this to
of this magic system that we're
inventing and on and the way we need to
do that is by creating entry points for
our negative engineering hooks so here's
what that might look like and if you
don't see the difference I'll highlight
it all we've done is introduce these
decorators which will tell our system
these are the tasks they're gonna be
they're gonna run keep an eye on them
manage their state manage their data
dependencies and then down here we've
created a workflow we're saying hey this
is my computational graph it's any
Python and I want you to pay attention
to what happens this is going to be the
workflow that we run in the future and
that's it I don't have to explain
anything else in theory it's all here so
there's one last thing that we need and
that's to import prefect so this is real
this works today this is actually our
hello world and this is the first time
that we've ever shown it publicly which
is kind of cool for us my team has
worked incredibly hard to build this API
not to mention the system that powers it
and we're very excited that we're going
to be open sourcing it in the very near
future and I promise that it fails more
successfully than anything you've
scene in fact the most important thing
that we did with prefect was that we
allowed it to fail successfully prefect
will track the state and result of every
task in your workflow and let them
depend on each other in a variety of
ways we use these rich state objects the
currency of the system and we allow
users to apply semantics to those
objects don't worry we have sensible
defaults so you don't actually have to
do anything more than what I showed a
moment ago if you don't want to so a
traditional data pipeline implemented in
Prefect would ignore state and just pass
data a more complex pipeline might use
the state to make decisions maybe to
kick off a cleanup job and oh really out
there workflow could actually use could
actually let failed tasks return data
for example their own exception and use
that to drive Diagnostics downstream as
we think these abstractions become
incredibly powerful and they are only
possible because the system is agnostic
to our applicants to its application it
is failing successfully and I want to
mention that under the hood we are using
desc to drive pretty much all the
execution we think that Basques is one
of the best tools out there and was
actually when I really got my hands on
desk as a data scientist that I thought
for the first time that something like
prefect might even be possible and will
have a lot more to say about that very
soon so one last thing since I've been
talking a lot about air flow today I
spent years on air flow it's a very
important tool to me it's a very
important tool to the data engineering
community I do think it has some flaws
prefect does not share any code with air
flow but it will run air flow for you
and so we have some partners who are
using prefect to modernize their air
flow stack without losing any of the
work that they put into building it so I
want to thank you all for coming to my
talk about failure if you'd rather talk
about success we're working with a
number of partners to develop prefect
and if you're in this room today we
would love to work with you you can
reach us at this address which is hello
at prefect IO or come find us outside
we're the guys who have been handing out
free compass coffee all day and since I
think we have a little bit of time left
um do we yeah then I'm happy to take
some questions
if there are any
[Music]
[Applause]
or if there aren't yes one second hey
Arno media capital one so the question I
have is when we look at some of these
workflows obviously there's all the
problems that happen operationally and
then there's all of the things than the
challenges that we face what we're
trying to develop them trying to figure
it out debug it piece it through how can
you compare and contrast what you're
promising so far with Prefect
in terms of as I am building a workflow
what the debugging process looks like
getting into the state being able to
develop locally versus sort of that
deployment stage so this will run on
your local machine if you want to run it
in a synchronous process so you can
actually put breakpoints and inspect
them that's totally fine we do that for
our own testing if you want to run it in
a local desk cluster or even using a
desk synchronous executor that's totally
fine and then you can also deploy this
at you know into a cluster very easily
but these are these are just functions
there they're exposed in this form to
you and they will do whatever it is that
you want one of the one of the core
design principles of prefect is that the
tasks themselves are black boxes we we
don't really care what's in them we're
agnostic to it we actually don't even
receive the code from our partners sort
of an important privacy barrier that
we've created so you can do whatever you
want interact with your systems however
you want we really don't care frankly so
if you need to debug this locally go you
just call it as a function you don't
even have to run the flow it's it's not
tied to anything unless you want it to
be so this is actually we worked very
hard on this so I like to show it off
this is sort of our functional API it's
not actually running the functions it's
just building a computational graph
similar to you know any deep learning
tool that you might use today we have a
fully class-based you know system behind
it just like air flow if you want to
call set upstream if you want to
manipulate tasks and edges directly you
you absolutely can if I had added a line
here that was flowed out run
you would receive back a dictionary with
all of the state objects from all of the
tasks in that run you could manipulate
them and examine them and do whatever
you want with them you can even crack
open the hood and see how we're working
with them so to be clear yeah we have a
functional API we also have what we call
our imperative API for more programmatic
access but this is more fun could you
talk more about integration with airflow
I kind of made it you sounded like you
made a promise if I keep working in air
flow then you promise me something this
is better later on I'm not like hosts in
terms of like six months of development
of like bunch of tags we we I challenged
my team to did I do that I challenged my
team to translate airflow into prefect
which I thought would be rather doable
based on my knowledge of prefect based
on my knowledge of air flow we decided
not to do that because there are some
features of air flow that we don't
support with a direct analog X comms
being one of them we have what we think
is a much stronger data dependency
feature that we're that we're showing
here and we didn't want to write
translation logic that we would then
have to maintain so we're working with
some of our partners some of whom are
actually other airflow PMC's who are
using prefect to instrument their
airflow deploys so you keep your airflow
database running you keep air flow
running we have flow in prefect which
creates a copy a one four one copy of
every task in your dag loads it into
prefix so that you can use all of our
instrument respectin tools you can use
our API you can use our UI to examine it
and run it but at the end of the day
it's calling back to airflow to run your
existing system so we've abandoned the
idea of translating it because we just
refuse to support some features
maybe this is a weird thing to say but
so I use a Z in my career before and I'm
using air flow right now and you know
I've never been a JavaScript programmer
but you see the like the rise and death
of like JavaScript frameworks and
visualizations of that one of the
reasons well we chose the Oracle flow
because of the utility to us but we also
were excited as someone on Google cloud
platform that they kind of made it a
first-class citizen with cloud composer
do you see this world is like the coming
and dying of the same way we have
JavaScript frameworks like what's hot
right now in terms of workflow
orchestration and it's like next year
like I'm gonna be applying for air flow
jobs if you're like I don't care about
that at all I in that time is it just
like are there still like as you were
saying people make these things and they
open source and then everybody makes a
ton of demands about what they should do
and then they're like it wasn't designed
to do that and they're like okay now on
the next one I think that's the first
time anyone's ever described the
workflow manager space is hot to me I
had I had to beg people to take me
seriously when I said that this was even
possible I mean we've had conversations
with people who deny that it's possible
until we show them how we how we did it
air flow is close to four years old now
and nothing has unseated it and so while
it has gained momentum and to be clear I
am an air flow PMC I am extremely
excited to see that I think I have the
third most commits of anyone in the
world on air flow it's an amazing thing
but it's not a hot space it's not a
crowded space I'm frankly amazed that we
see this emergence of an air flow
developer like I'm not sure that's a
good thing to be honest with you sort of
my argument here is that the workflow
system should fade right you shouldn't
be an air flow developer you should be a
developer who happens to use air flow
any other questions yes we have we've
designed our compute to be modular at
the moment we preferred ask and we used
ask running in kubernetes like how do
you sorry I mean how do you had let's
suppose suppose you have one step that's
got a lot of different software than the
next step like how would you address
that a lot of different dependencies yes
so software dependencies yeah no it's a
good question today the the workflow is
built as a container with a single set
of dependencies you put them all in and
we're working towards supporting an
individual container per task yeah yeah
okay okay is that a hint are we supposed
to get out okay I'm happy to take
questions as long as there are yes
there you go thank you my apologies if
you already answer this but I know many
people have found frustrations with
distributing airflow drops using celery
just with the complications of a celery
and things what's the story for prefect
surround running a cluster where jobs
are run across it sure so that's what we
used ask for tasks is hands-down the
best way to do that can you describe
that a little bit further assuming
people know I know about tasks and
assuming others do can you describe how
it yeah we're just best voice one of the
easiest ways I've found to describe desk
is actually a sort of a pure Python and
friendly version of SPARC so desk is I
think just an extremely easy way to
distribute computation across any number
of nodes whether it's your local laptop
or something running in the cloud
it'll take a function it'll serialize it
it'll run it in the cloud they'll bring
back a result or what's really cool
about it and what we'd like to take
advantage of is you can dynamically
build yet further graphs from an already
running graph so I mean in a nutshell is
just a very easy way to run distributed
computations frankly it's the best I've
seen so we use it for our primary
execution engine it's modular if
somebody wants to write a an extension
for something else they absolutely could
you want to go back to celery by all
means go right ahead but we're promoting
desk as our as our primary executor yes
do you expose the that you're running on
tasks at all to the users thank do they
get to see the task dashboard is there
any exposure of that at all it's a great
question so at the moment no but not
because we've decided not to we just
sort of haven't addressed that question
so it's a good one we don't hide that
we're running us in fact we would invite
users who want to take advantage of the
fact that we're running in DES to just
open up a worker client and we're trying
to figure out the right way to create a
sort of first-class API where you could
still run that locally effectively and
do and do your debugging but also have
it work properly in a distributed
environment so we we don't hide it from
users we also at the moment aren't
explicitly promoting it to users it's
just a it's an important act this
all right well thank you all so much I
appreciate your attention in your time